with election day just two days away
candidates are doing everything they can
to get your vote a big piece of the
puzzle this year are Asian American
Community they make up about 10 percent
of eligible voters and that's twice as
many as the rest of the nation I spoke
with some this week about what they're
hoping to see on November 8th
it is exploded as someone who's grown up
in Las Vegas Tina Kwong describes the
expansion she's seen of the Asian
American Community back then there was
hardly even an Asian supermarket and now
we have an entire Chinatown and as that
population grows many including Quan are
heading to the polls with the midterm
election just days away Asian Americans
are a key component to political Victory
making up about 10 percent of the
state's eligible voters of course you
want the people creating laws that
affect your community Sonny vanilla
Executive Board member of the aapi
Nevada Chamber of Commerce says while
different members of the state's fastest
growing minority community may lean on
different sides of the aisle cultural
and societal representation is crucial
as candidates and lawmakers make their
case it's very very important for us to
know that we are contributing to this
community and that we're a vital part of
the community while Tina is happy to see
changes moving forward she wants to
encourage others to use their voice
we're not a single voice we have
different experiences different
personalities this coming election day
and every other future opportunity
if a future matters to you the future of
everyone else around you matters to you
then you need to stand up
says another factor of representation is
the approximately 22 000 Asian American
business owners here in southern Nevada